you
you know I had a lot of chance to
interact with your class over the last
couple of years starting with admin
weekend I guess about twenty-seven
months ago so we've had lots of
interactions large and small but never
anything quite like a last lecture come
in come in so I'm looking forward to it
I I have assembled the list of of ten
lessons that have been important to me
in my life that I'd like to share with
you so if it's all right let's charge in
this first one I guess comes from two
sources one as you know I spent seven
years my life living and working in
Australia where cricket is a national
game but I also spent the last nine
years teaching a second year seminar on
leadership and in that leadership
seminar I like to use the case of siRNAs
Shackleton the great Antarctic Explorer
and Shackleton had something very
interesting to say about life he said
some people say it's wrong to think of
life as a game I don't think so he said
life to me means the greatest of all
games the danger lies in treating it as
a trivial game a game to be taken
lightly
and a game where the rules don't matter
much the rules he said matter a great
deal Shackleton said you know the game
has to be played fairly or it's no game
at all
and even to win the game is not the
chief end the chief end is to win it
honorably and splendidly and it shackled
his mind honorably and spent splendidly
meant living it by his values the things
that mattered most to him
by his rules now
those of you know cricket know it's got
a lot of rules but another thing about
cricket that I think is relevant it's a
long game
you know life ebbs and flows and
endurance is a virtue stamina is very
important work at staying in shape work
at staying in shape physically mentally
emotionally in many respects your
determination and your drive will have
as much to do with your life as your DNA
like cricket it's a long game you need
to pace yourself
and another thing a well-known cricket
commentator observed is that in addition
to being a long game or perseverance and
resilience and patience are critical
it's a game where he said nothing
happens and then everything happens
again only true cricket aficionados
might appreciate this but applying it to
life I can tell you that often out of
the blue that big opportunity or that
big challenge hits you in the face you
can't plan your life you can't plan your
career but you can plan to be prepared
and preparation is an awfully key aspect
number 9 now this is a lesson that I got
over and over again from our CEO at
Wells Fargo Karl Reichert he'd like to
say this I don't think Karl necessarily
believed the world was divided into good
people and bad people but we all grew up
understanding that there were people
with very bad behaviors you know and
life is too short you don't have to deal
with people who are abusive people who
are dishonest people who are unethical
you can just say no in fact you better
just say no you know in banking where
you make loans every day you take
deposits every day you accept
investments you you have a lot of
opportunities to say yes and no even at
the GSB when raising money there are
times when it's appropriate to say no
because the motivation isn't right
and I think this lesson aside from
saving you an awful lot of
unpleasantness can also save you because
o goat backwards because your reputation
is everything and you've got to guard it
scrupulously for me a corollary to this
life too short lesson has been another
one I've always applied which is don't
sign something you haven't read don't
sign something you don't understand
or that you don't agree with life's too
short
this is another Wells Fargo ism this is
a this is a slogan or a phrase is still
very much a part of the company today
and it's something that we began
adopting when we wanted very much to
change the culture from one that was
more bureaucratic to one with a real
sense of accountability you know when
you think about a small store and you
encounter the person that owns that
store you have a much different
experience and encounter then when
you're dealing with a temporary hired
clerk that sense of ownership that comes
from true ownership is is a very real
and different behavior that we all
recognize and we all appreciate run it
like you own it spend it like it was
your own money not somebody else's or
somebody else's enterprise whenever
you're in charge of something anything
anywhere any group if you adopt that
ownership mindset and mentality it
serves you well after all next Johnny
leadership is not about fame and fortune
and power it is about responsibility and
it's a responsibility for the group that
you have inherited it's a responsibility
for helping that group to be better
to helping that group to do better and
that's that same responsibility that an
owner feels of his or her establishment
that is often missing when you come to
somebody working for a large
organization you know the challenge in a
big organization is if you can get
everyone in every group to have that
same ownership mindset you see in a
small shop or a small business if
everyone in the group can adopt and have
that kind of sense of run it like you
own it you create a culture and a
climate of discipline and accountability
that has enormous power and energy for
the enterprise
another thing about running like you own
it next Johnny is that when you have
that sort of mindset attention to detail
really matters you know in the post
Enron and world comm world we got
sarbanes-oxley a lot of people love to
complain and whinge about sarbanes-oxley
too much paperwork too many rules and
yet you at the same time you would see
CEOs in front of Congress saying well
mr. congressman understanding the
accounting wasn't part of my job and
that lack of ownership if you will of
the details is a real sign of difficulty
if it was your business you'd want it to
be in control you would want it to be
under good control without surprises
that's not micromanaging but it is
investing the time that it takes to
really understand what's going on in the
operation you can't manage and lead
something you don't understand and a
final point about ownership next Johnny
is it just like the owner of a small
enterprise when you have something that
you own people will watch what you do
they'll watch how you do it much more
than they'll listen to what you say
in particular they'll watch what you pay
attention to because leaders really do
cast long shadows so run it like you own
it number seven this one I think is
particularly important for GSB graduates
I know it was for me in my career in
life you know when you think about
leadership in management you often think
we think about leading a team leading a
group and it's our group that we're
responsible for and you think you spend
most of your time managing downward
working with the team building a lot of
excitement and enthusiasm building
loyalty and commitment and achieving
whatever it is that that team is about
to achieve so we spend a lot of time
managing down and yes there's an
understanding that you know I should
spend some of my time managing up the
boss needs to know what's going on the
board needs to be aware of what's going
on the regulator's need to know what's
going on but this kind of we have an up
and down mindset often and yet we often
forget next that wherever you find
yourself you're always part of some team
you need to manage these relationships
with peers and other team members you
want to be part of a winning
organization that means you need the
strongest team possible that means other
parts have to do just as well as your
group if you're going to be successful
even a CEO is part of a team call the
board of directors a Dean of a school is
part of a team the executive cabinet of
the University and another way of
viewing this I think is on the next
slide you know don't be so competitive
that you just stick to that narrow job
description of your own job wherever you
are think about your unit yes but the
entire company and if you're in charge
of the entire company think about your
industry and if you're an industry
leader think about your country
or your world in terms of the way your
mind operates and works don't forget to
manage sideways it's a big world out
there number six
I'm sure the number one reason that
leaders fail is because of hubris they
take themselves too seriously as I would
put here in other words they stop
listening they stop learning
they start believing in their own unique
importance they forget that an awful lot
of success has to do with luck and
timing the work of others you leave here
I know with great confidence and you
should have great confidence given who
you are and all that you've done and
what you know as you leave here you
should have self-confidence but there's
always a fine line between confidence
and arrogance and on the next slide know
don't let yourself cross that line
leadership is about earning followers
people want to follow a genuine leader
they don't want to follow a
self-proclaimed self-important one
that's not who you want to follow and
that's not who you want to be when
you're interested in motivating and
attracting other people to your cause
you know in his book good to great our
alum gem Collins who taught here and
obviously got his MBA here this is one
of the what 25 best-selling business
books of all time he coined this term
level 5 leadership and in Jim's concept
of level 5 leadership it was not
arrogance but humility that he saw in
these people combined with a very very
discipline focus on the organization's
needs in other words take your job
seriously
take the group and its needs seriously
just don't take yourself that seriously
when it comes to attributing what's
making all this happen and I think
another way to keep yourself humble is
stay close to people at the entry level
stay around people that are smarter than
you stay around people that will give
you honest feedback feedback is one of
life's great gifts feedback man you know
what's right that's absolutely when
you're lucky enough to get honest
feedback treated as what it is one of
life's great gifts stay around a
university it gives you great
perspective on the future number five
I'm not sure who actually came up with
this saying you find it a lot if you
look on the web and google it I don't
know who the original source was but I
heard it at one time and it had a lot of
resonance for me you know there are a
lot of powerful emotions in life there's
there's greed and there's envy and and
fear is certainly one of them and fear
can impact us in a number of ways it can
cause you to withdraw and just not deal
with a situation it can cause you to
freeze in the sense you just can't
decide and you can't move but it can
also give you the courage to act to risk
to change when change is appropriate to
change yourself when change is required
my wife said to me no fear can paralyze
you or it can energize you and it can
energize you to seek those changes in
your life that are really critical when
it's time for you to make a change and
in doing so be prepared I think in three
dimensions number one the next leve be
prepared to take intelligent risks as I
would call them here you know use your
powers of analysis what am i afraid of
why am i afraid what's the worst
that can happen have I got it covered
there there is an approach to problem
solving an analysis that I would call
intelligence an intelligent risk taking
and use that power of analysis to unlock
some of the fear but also be prepared to
trust your instincts how does it feel in
addition to what is my analysis show and
it's that combination I think of your
analysis and your gut feeling that can
give you the courage to act when action
is called for and finally you know you
don't have to be alone in all this I
remember when I went to the first
parents weekend at my daughter's
undergraduate college and the person up
front speaking said to the parents as we
were sitting out there well you know
we're trying to get these young men and
women to understand that asking for help
is an act of Independence it's not a
sign of weakness and I thought as a
wonderful sentiment you know I heard
that now almost 25 years ago but it's so
true and yet it's so often not accepted
or practiced we see it as a sign of
weakness
Linda Hill in her studies of MBA
graduates of the Harvard Business School
go off to their first time jobs as
managers or in managerial roles which
can be a real struggle a lot of
difficulty in terms of why am I having
so much problem here she said in fewer
than half the cases that people actually
asked for help which is pretty amazing
you don't have to face these fears alone
you can ask for help it's not a sign of
weakness it is an act of Independence
number four I had a wonderful director
at Westpac named Chris Stewart and every
time we seem to confront the most
difficult problems and challenges the
kind that led to sleep deprivation and
cause your stomach to churn a bit he
would have a smile on his face and say
this is such a character-building
experience I didn't necessarily fight it
all out of music at the time but I came
to appreciate over and over again just
how right he was
and you know in particular when I've
reviewed the literature and the research
on adult learning and you realize you
know adults learn most of what they
learn through experience and in
particular they learn the most we learn
the most when we have to acquire a skill
or develop a behavior that's necessary
for us to accomplish something that's
really important to us that's when we
learn the most and that is almost always
without question when you step outside
your comfort zone that's when you get
these character building experiences so
don't stay in that zone too long you've
got to stretch yourself give yourself a
cold call you need these experiences
you'll learn the most from these
experiences they will do the most for
you in life and then when you have these
experiences the key is to learn from
them you know how often do we see two
people have a pretty similar experience
and yet you can see a huge difference in
the way people might react or learn from
that experience there is the experience
there is the feedback hopefully you
might get there's the listening you
might do in particular there's the
reflection on what was this experience
trying to teach me and then learning
from that and integrating it into who
you are and growing and really
reinventing yourself becoming a
different person as a consequence of
that experience you know learnings
learning's are not possessions like
diplomas that you put in a drawer or
frame on the wall your learnings are
things that you integrate into your life
and who you are and change yourself
because of what you've learned I had a
boss a different boss at Wells Fargo not
Carl Riker but another CEO who said you
know I've got to leave you in this job
long enough so that your mistakes bite
you in the rear end and again like the
character building experience of my
director I didn't necessarily get it
until I started to have some mistakes
that bit me right where he said and in
particular you know I hired the wrong
person in a very important role now how
do you learn to hire people usually by
hiring the wrong person that's the first
thing and having to live with that
and work your way out of it so that you
don't make the same mistake twice
so there is a certain resilience that
comes from having to learn from
experience number three this comes from
my great great friend and role model and
somebody that was such an inspiration
John Gardner John taught here at the
business school he taught at the ed
school he passed away about eight years
ago but one of America's great human
beings and John had a wonderful phrase
you know he said leaders find the words
leaders find the words and he was
talking about the fact that leadership
is about earning followers and you earn
followers through honest communication a
communication that connects with people
and the only way you know if it's
connecting is to try the words and to
try different words and it rarely works
with that first set of words that you
might try and it could be the second or
the third or beyond it might be a story
it might be an analogy
it might be relating it to whatever
connects with the audience leaders find
the words you know it's interesting at
the Reunion here just a few weeks ago
one of the students that was in my
seminar last year he came up to me said
you know we had to lay off 40% of the
people where I work and I kept thinking
over and over again what you said in the
seminar leaders find the words and he
really worked he said I worked so hard
at finding the right things to say it's
not a beat it's not a big speech it's
not about big a big speech it's often
best to think of it as just an honest
conversation as someone once observed in
the next slide no after all life is an
endless series of conversations it's so
true that's how you build relationships
is through conversation and it's
building relationships that is the
essence of how you lead people and
organizations it is all about building
relationships with the people so if
someone asked you to give a talk or ask
you to teach do it you'll find the words
I know number two
use critical analytical thinking and the
GSB learning throughout your life it
works you know we had a former faculty
member here used to delight in saying to
the classes as they left he'd say you
know you're not as smart as you think
you are but you've learned a lot more
here than you know I want to board in
Australia of a company and we have a
young General Counsel there a couple
years ago she said to me you know I've
noticed that you always seem to have the
right question that just gets right to
the heart of the issue just enough to
cause the management team to squirm a
little bit because they haven't nailed
it down but get to the issue and get us
to solve a really difficult challenge
she said to me how do you learn to do
that
and I thought to myself well I think it
starts at the GSB that's where it
started you know that's where I learned
to think very clearly about well what's
the problem why is it a problem what are
the alternative solutions to the problem
how are we going to go about evaluating
those alternatives and get to a decision
that seems to make sense it's a real
skill a real learning and then to take
that learning and translate that into a
skill that you developed through
practice you know lots and lots of
reviews listening a lot of people
beginning to recognize patterns when you
pose a question and you really can
develop the art of asking great
questions Ron Heifetz who's a leadership
scholar at the Kennedy School at a
marvelous phrase that I think is really
really great he said you know one one
can lead with no more than a question in
hand and it is often so true that asking
that penetrating question that you learn
to get a start on here is the real a
real beginning and leadership
number one I'd like to talk with you in
this last point about personal renewal
you know John Gardner who said leaders
find the words was passionate about
leadership but his other passion was
about something he called personal
renewal and particularly later in his
life after he was about 70 he was quite
interested he wrote some of the most
interesting things I think some of the
most insightful about personal renewal
and what John observed was he said you
know I'm puzzled I'm puzzled why some
men and women go to seed and others
remain vital all throughout their lives
he said I'm not talking about a failure
to get to the top in some achievement
said that's not the point anyway he
agreed with Shackleton on this that's
not the point but he said I'm talking
about people who for whatever reason
stop learning and growing and they're
operating far below the level of their
potential it is John said as if their
clock stopped now he observed you know
most people enjoy learning and growing
and to do that it's critical it's very
important to make a periodic
self-assessment how am i doing in the
learning and growing department it
starts with that awareness awareness is
a key because if you're going to make a
change if you're going to fix the course
you're on to a better course if you're
going to get that clock that maybe is
slowing down rewound you have to start
with that assessment how am i doing in
the learning and growing department and
I hope you'll do that periodically
throughout your life but I also hope
when you
when you engage in such assessment that
you won't be too hard on yourself
that's something John kasha don't be too
hard on yourself he said someone once
observed that life is the art of drawing
without an eraser he said it's good to
look back for lessons learned but look
forward for optimism for change for
confidence but above all when making
those assessments don't imagine that the
story is over
you know life John said has a lot of
chapters just keep learning learning is
not just for young people learning is a
lifelong journey learn from your
mistakes as he said we we all want to be
interesting we want to be interesting
people and the way to be interesting is
to be interested so be interested be
curious care about things risk failure
and reach out to other people life John
said is not a mountain that has a summit
and it's not a game that has a final
score it is he said an endless unfolding
it's an endless process of
self-discovery it's an endless and
unpredictable dialogue between our own
potentialities and they are much greater
than you can ever imagine our own
potentialities and life situations in
which we find ourselves the challenges
will keep changing but life pulls things
out of you he took particular delight in
examples of people who were over 70 and
or at least in that age group and kept
opening new chapters John Paul the 23rd
was made Pope when he was 76 years old
but he launched the most vigorous
renewal of the church that had been seen
in a century
Winston Churchill was 66 when he became
prime minister in 1940 you know a friend
of Churchill said he was a man who J
walked through life but as John observe
you know it's okay to be a late bloomer
if you don't miss the Flower Show and
Churchill didn't miss it
Ronald Reagan turned seventy two weeks
before or two weeks after his first
inauguration life has many chapters if
you allow them to open and above all as
John said you know we all want a life of
meaning we want our lives to have
meaning and he said what meaning is not
something you stumble across you have to
build meaning into your life and you
build that meaning into your life by the
commitments that you make perhaps
your commitment will be to your life's
work perhaps to your loved ones perhaps
your religion perhaps to your fellow
human beings the important thing is that
they be commitments beyond yourself you
know as John said self preoccupation is
a prison and the key to getting out of
that prison are these commitments to
something beyond yourself when we're
young we search for identity Who am I
and what will my identity be and as John
said your identity is what you've
committed yourself to and it is so much
the case at any point in your life where
your commitments are becomes your
identity and at any moment in time that
may simply mean just doing a better job
at what you're doing that may be your
commitment and that's a great commitment
as John said and a marvelous phrase
that's been quoted over and over
again some men and women make the world
a better place
just by being the kind of people they
are they have the gift of kindness or
courage or loyalty or integrity and to
be that kind of person would be worth
all the years of living and learning so
keep learning never stop keep trying
pick yourself up when you fall stay
interested so that you'll be interesting
stay involved but above all make and
keep commitments commitments to things
greater than you so you can keep
building meaning into your lives and my
greatest wish tonight for each of you
for each of you would be a life with
meaning and I take great comfort in
knowing that such lives will make the
world a better place
so that's my top 10 and I thank you for
the privilege of being invited to give a
last lecture to the class of 2010 thank
you
by the deforming
here at the school yeah yeah we
certainly had a situation starting in
the fall of o8 when we could see our
endowment revenues were going to be down
and our giving was going to be down and
the last thing I you know this was my
last year and I didn't want to turn the
school over to the new Dean with the
expenses going up in the revenues going
this way and I guess I'd had the benefit
of living through quite a few recessions
and ups and downs and recognizing again
that's this pattern recognition
recognizing that the best way to deal
with these situations is to deal quickly
you know confront reality and deal with
it I had a director Wells Fargo who
actually was the Dean of the business
school at the time RJ Miller famed for
friends of RJ Millers and RJ had a
wonderful saying at the board he'd say
you know if you have to cut off a dog's
tail do it once don't do it an inch at a
time for the poor dog you know and it's
so you know it's painful but we also
knew look the best thing is to get it
get it right size the way it should be
we ended up having to layoff 50 staff
people and make some decisions about
what would stay open and not but to
figure the priorities make the move do
it and get on with it you know and it's
never easy
it's never easy I think having done it a
few times and know you're doing it for
the right reason you're doing it for the
good of the greater group and it turns
out to be easier in that sense but it's
never easy but that was you know I've
been there before I could see the bad
news coming better to get on it and get
on it early and I certainly didn't want
to leave it to dean saloner to have to
have to do that and most you know
interestingly the the rest of the
university kind of caught the same
momentum and we really are much better
as a university on top of things a lot
of universities are still now in a
budget cutting rollback phase where as
stanford made the move and and we're in
much better shape today
yeah which CEOs do you must admire my Oh
golly you know there are a lot of people
I have admired today unfortunately the
world of CEOs is it has come to the
point where no one trusts anybody and I
think part of the promise compensation
I think compensation got out of whack I
admire Jack Welch enormously when Jack
was CEO had my own Bill Gates
I admired Meg Whitman when she was
running eBay animal ke he is a friend of
my admire enormously for the way she
inherited what she did at Xerox without
any experience and pulled him out of the
doldrums and has really got them back on
track and I particularly admire people
who have taken important institutions
that got off the rails and brought them
back I have huge admiration for Steve
Jobs who got fired when he was the CEO
of Apple once he came back later and
like resurrected ended into a whole new
company I'm there they're just there are
lots and lots of great admiration for
the CEOs we've got a Wells Fargo Carl
Reichert dick Cooley so it's dick
cabassa [ __ ] and what he build when we
brought the two together now there are
lots and lots of really great CEOs out
there and great leaders but it's it's
very hard now to get much in the way of
decent press and it's it's difficult for
CEOs to get much air time I think but
then and that's partly a problem of
compensation yeah
yourself
yes I you know I think the the things
that hit me the most was when I had some
of the biggest struggles and the biggest
challenges that I needed to change we
needed to change an organization we
needed to change a company or change the
unit whether I was at Westpac in
Australia or the business I inherited it
Wells Fargo in various areas and it took
me quite a while to realize you know
you're not getting any change of you
don't change I think that's the single
biggest learning that I didn't have a
business school but I got later you know
you have to you have to model the
changes you want other people to to
implement if you want more customer
orientation if you want more attention
to detail if you want more discipline
around finance whatever it is that's
really critical to make the organization
successful you you have to you have to
be willing to change yourself and
oftentimes people aren't you know
they'll bring in a consultant they'll
run a training program and have other
people do the training and I kind of
learned the hard way that that you know
you have to do it yourself you you have
to lead the training if you want to run
a program for all your senior management
you better lead the first class and show
what you're willing to do yourself and
therefore what you want to other people
what you expect from other people so you
know I guess I went through that the
hardest for me I was in 1981 I had a
group at Wells Fargo that I inherited
and I got you know needed change and I
gave some orders it was something and
six people emailed me that they were
quitting and they quit they went to
forma they went to a competitor to form
a competing firm
so that was a character-building
experience I suddenly everyone was gone
and I was able to recruit a person very
successfully but he said look you've got
to go out there and apologize to all our
clients and that was hard for me I
didn't you know I thought well I didn't
do anything wrong I was trying to get
this thing right that's the way they see
it and I think too that that was part of
a reinvention
to be able to say oh you know he's right
I could have done it better and I think
that's one of the one of the things
about you know I'm not talking about
being a different person you know you
have to be yourself but as we talked
about in class you can be yourself with
more skill and that's what reinvention
is about is getting more skillful at
being yourself you know I don't know how
many of you have Deb grünfeld acting
with power but you know I know in
talking to Debbie I love what she's
trying to do because you know she's
talking about using more than just your
brain power
you know we all leave here as MBA
students very good at the analytics and
using our brains but we're not
necessarily good at using our emotions
that are ourselves sometimes and other
aspects of our personality and in
particular just yourself as an actor a
lot of people would say and she says I
can't do that That's not me
and that question well how do you know
if you've never tried that part of you
often you've only exercised about this
much of who you might be
and I think willing to take those risks
I've become I've really came to see
particularly in leadership is an awful
lot as John Gardner said you know
leadership is an art it's a performing
art and you're the instrument and you've
got to use every bit of that instrument
that you can you know and that may and
that it doesn't just include your
analytical brainpower so there's an
awful lot of that I learned along the
way and and I'm still learning you know
I think particularly the power of
symbolism and the power of what you
might call almost what an actor you know
you think of an actor getting into
character he's trying to connect with
the audience in an emotional way as well
as an intellectual way and I think I
think that's something that I try to
develop over the last 10 or 15 years of
my career
what am I currently don't have time for
that I'd like to have time for oh you
know my I should be spending more time
with my wife but but I spending time now
with my family and my grandkids and I'm
spending time doing some things I really
enjoy doing I'm working a back in
banking again I'm working with Citigroup
quite a bit I'm working with Bechtel and
I'm doing a little teaching and that's
kind of how what I'd like to do I'd like
to work with a couple of companies I
admire and would like to help in one
case get back on track in another case
just a great company and I'd like to
spend some more time teaching and
stretching myself in that dimension yeah
you've seen a lot of classes leave the
GSB I'm wondering if you can comment on
what mistakes you see them make commonly
out of the gates and how we might avoid
making the same mistake what mistake do
I see people making out of the gates
well I don't I don't know that I what I
all I can tell you is what I hear you
know in feedback from from alums and
feedback from recruiters I think by and
large our students do a tremendous job
and they get started out of the gate
very good if there's one mistake they
make out of the gate is relying so much
on the analytics and on the intellectual
and less on the teamwork or the peer
relations I think just the interpersonal
skills the people management but I think
our students do that better than any
other group of MBAs in the world so
they've all had touchy feely right thing
you know I hear lots of great things
about us but I think I think if there's
something to be on guard for it's that
it's that managing side way that was a
huge thing I never even thought about
that till I was about 15 years into my
career realized how many enemies I was
making of my peers because I was just so
focused on doing a good job and I felt
if I do a good job I'll get ahead I'll
be fine and I just wasn't focused on
those peer relationships like I should
have been it doesn't mean schmoozing and
all that it just means being aware of
what they're trying to do and what it
takes for them to be successful because
it's hard for it's hard for me to be
successful if the other units also are
even though I even though they don't
they're not my responsibility if I'm
thinking about the greater good they are
my responsibility
yeah they how do you gain the
credibility and trust of local
stakeholders and what are some of the
main big falls you've seen managers make
when meeting internationally for the
first time I think I think the biggest
challenge in working in another culture
which usually were talking about another
country but I know in my case even I saw
academia as another culture and it
really it really was almost like another
country you know to come here because of
just you know the way people think the
the things they value the way decisions
get made are different that's I think
the biggest mistake people make and
another culture is they make too many
assumptions they just assume that this
is the way people are thinking and
acting and behaving that it's they come
from their frame of reference years ago
the first time I was involved in Japan
for example it was very easy to make a
mistake that that the good English
speakers were the bright ones because
those are the ones you could connect
with they communicate with and we often
put the good English speaker in a job
when they really weren't the best for
that job and that's a kind of assumption
that you make that's really flawed and
so you make the assumption that because
someone's quiet they haven't got
anything to offer but in fact they have
a lot to offer you've got to find a way
to to bring them out so I think the
biggest mistakes are not taking the time
to understand the culture you never
fully understand those of you know that
and you never fully understand it but
you need to spend a huge of
at I'm listening so probably a mistake
out of the boxes you know too much
talking and not enough listening
particularly if you find yourself in
another culture I think that's that's
the biggest challenge and you know you
never can learn you'll never learn and
understand deeply another culture but so
I think partly is to recognize that and
to be quite humble about that and do
your best at listening a lot and trying
to figure out you know what is the value
system and the things going on in that
culture so that you might be more
effective anything else
Casey we got where you want to get yeah
thank you